[MUSIC PLAYING]
KAREN LELAND: Good afternoon.
Well, I am so
delighted to be here.
Google is really one
of my favorite places
to work and to talk.
So what I want to
talk about today
is I want to talk about
what I call the contribution
gap and our personal brands.
So a few years ago, I
had a six month period,
and in that six month period
I left a long marriage--
after a couple of decades--
and got a divorce.
My step-- all within six
months-- my stepfather
dropped dead.
My stepfather died
of a lung disease.
My father dropped dead after a
heart attack two weeks later.
I moved from
California to New York
and then back to
California again.
And as one of my friends said--
you know how
there's those scales
of things you're not supposed
to do because they can kill you?
There's things like
move or a death
in the family-- they
increase the rate of death.
She said, you're
not supposed to do
even one of them,
let alone all six
of them in a short
period of time.
And so it really made me stop.
And I had to stop, and
I had to step back,
and I had to take
a look at, what
did I want the next
period of my life to be?
What really was my contribution
in the next period of my life?
And so I went on this long,
yearlong research project
about--
what is really at the
heart of our contribution?
What is really at the heart
of our personal brands?
And what I want to
share with you today
is what I found
out in that year,
because what I found
out in that year
really changed my own personal
brand-- it changed how I think
about things, it
changed how I work,
it changed how I
work with clients.
And I found that, in
that research that I did,
there's a lot we can learn about
our brands and our contribution
that isn't always the way
that we talk about them.
So that's what I want to
talk about with you today.
I want to share what I learned
in that research with you
today.
The first thing I want
to ask you to do--
I know everyone's sat
down-- but the first thing
I'd love to ask
everybody to do is just
to stand up for one minute.
And I know you just sat down,
but stand up for one minute--
and what I'd like you to do is
say hello to one or two people
around you, only
here's the catch--
say hello like
you're really looking
for someone a lot more important
to say hello to, all right?
So if everybody would
just do that for a minute.
Go ahead and say hello.
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
KAREN LELAND: All right, now
would you please say hello
to somebody next to
you or around you,
but say hello like they're
your long-lost friend
and you're thrilled to
have found them again.
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
KAREN LELAND: All right, stop.
Very good, thank
you, and have a seat.
So you know how
in that first one,
it was a little bit
like, meh, so-so.
And the second one--
the volume-- I saw many
more hugs in the second one
and the volume goes up.
I think when we have
a really strong idea
of our personal brand, and
we have a really strong idea
of what we contribute,
it's much easier
to connect with other people.
It's almost like we walk
into the room with that,
because that sense of connection
is much more palatable.
And it isn't that it's bad--
the first experience--
it's just a little empty.
And what I call that is
the contribution gap.
When we're really clear
about our brand, when
we're really clear about
our contribution, then
what we have a way to
instantly almost connect
with other people--
Whether these are
people at a conference,
whether they're
people we work with,
whether they're people
in a social situation.
It gives us that sense of
what our contribution is.
We walk in with that.
And so what I studied
in that year that I had
was what the contribution
gap was in my own life
and what the contribution gap
was in other people's lives.
And one of the things
I found in my research
is one of the things that
gets in the way of our brands
being the strongest
and our contribution--
making our greatest
contribution--
is what I call
the myth of roles.
And this is all the
I ams in our life--
I am a mother.
I am a wife.
I am a software engineer.
I am a dancer.
I am a cat lover.
I am a dog lover.
I'm a fan of "Game of Thrones."
Whatever your I ams are,
whatever your roles are--
and so I discovered that
these roles, really,
are one of the things that get
in the way of our contribution.
And for some of you--
what are some of the
roles that you have?
You can just shout it out--
some of the roles that you
have, personal or professional.
AUDIENCE: Daughter.
KAREN LELAND: Daughter, exactly.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Husband.
KAREN LELAND: Husband, yes.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Room mate.
KAREN LELAND: Room
mate, exactly.
AUDIENCE: Googler.
KAREN LELAND: Googler,
yes, very important role.
But what's the problem
with all roles eventually?
What happens to all
roles eventually?
They end, right?
By their nature, all
roles eventually end.
And so if we think our
contribution or the heart
of our contribution
is about our roles,
then what happens
is-- when they end,
we find ourselves
going, well who am I?
What is it that I
have to contribute?
That's a lot of what
happened when my father died,
and I stopped being someone's--
my father's daughter.
I was still my
mother's daughter,
but when I stopped
being my father's
daughter-- or when
I got a divorce
and I was now not
someone's wife.
And you know, all
of these roles--
and I wasn't a
Californian anymore--
and so all these roles
started to change.
And I started to say, well, if
I'm not all of that, who am I?
So one of the things
that gets in the way
of our personal brands
and our contributions
is this myth of the roles--
who we think we are.
The other thing I discovered in
my research-- and by the way,
I interviewed several
thousand people
all over the world in
different companies.
And male, female,
despite age, race,
gender-- it didn't
matter-- what I
found was there was a
lot of commonalities.
And the other
commonality was this myth
of knowledge and results.
A lot of us define our
brands and our contribution
by the results we
produce or what we know.
The writer Gretchen Cryer calls
that, I know the worlds of.
So what are the
worlds that we know?
Like you might know the
worlds of volleyball,
or the world of travel,
or the world of Google,
or the world of speaking
French, or the world of dogs--
there's a million worlds
that you can know.
And all that is
part of our brand,
but that's not the heart
of our contribution
or the heart of our brand.
And so the other thing
I found in my research
is that people often get
very stifled because they
think that their brand--
or they think that
their contribution--
are these worlds that they know.
So if it's not those
two things, what is it?
Well, here's what I
found in my research.
I found that our brands
and our contribution--
at the heart of them is
what I call the weather
you bring with you.
It's the thing-- when
you walk into the room,
it just comes with you.
It's the thing that
people feel from us.
people can sense about us
and feel from us the moment
they walk into a room
without knowing
anything about us.
So I'll give you
an example of this.
I was walking in the Lower East
Side of Manhattan about a year
ago with a friend, and we see
this woman-- a traffic cop--
and she's directing traffic.
And she isn't just
directing traffic-- she's
doing it like it's ballet.
Now, I have the greatest respect
for New York City traffic cops.
That is a hard job,
but a lot of them
often have the
look on their face
like, this would be a great
job if it wasn't for all
those people driving cars.
And this woman is leaping,
and she's jumping,
and she's going, come
on, sir, go this way.
Ladies, cross the street.
She is so alive and
so enthusiastic,
and we're all just-- all the
pedestrians are standing there
like this--
wow.
And we're just watching this,
and the cars are honking at her
and waving, and she is this
great example of bringing
the weather you bring with you.
She has just got this
aliveness and this joy,
and she's making this
amazing contribution.
And of course, she's completely
establishing her brand
by what she's doing,
but she's doing it
in this really
enthusiastic, excited way.
And cars are honking--
and the thing that was
amazing about this woman was,
did she know she had a
solid role as a traffic cop?
Yes, I'm sure she did.
Was she knowledgeable?
Yes, I'm sure she was
knowledgeable in all thing
traffic laws.
But it wasn't her
role or her knowledge
that was making
a difference-- it
was the way she was doing it.
It was the weather that
she was bringing with her
that was making a difference.
And in the work that I did and
in the research that I did,
I actually found that
there's some archetypes
or there's some ways that
people typically contribute,
and I call these brand
energies or brand archetypes.
These are-- and there
were 12 of them.
I actually could
identify and find
12 core brand archetypes of how
we approach our personal brands
and how we contribute.
And the interesting thing
about these brand energies
is all of us have access
to all these energies.
Any of us can step into
any of these at any time.
But usually, there's
one or two that-- when
we look back to being kids--
we can see that way, way, way
back, we had this.
This is something that
we had, even as kids.
This has always, in a way, been
what we bring to the party.
It's been the weather
that we bring with us.
And so I wanted to go through
these 12 archetypes with you
because I want you to think
about-- as I go through them--
where do you see yourself?
But where do you see the
people that you work with?
Because one of the other
things I found in the research
was that the best
marriages, the best teams,
the best departments, the
best problem solving groups--
all of those people had people
with different contribution
styles with different
brand energies--
that it wasn't just one.
That when you had
people with a mix--
when you had more of a diversity
of contribution style--
things went a lot better because
people brought different things
to the party.
So I'm going to go through the
12 that I discovered with you.
Now, for the
overachievers in here
who are like, no, I'm not
just one or two, I'm all 12--
fine, you can be all 12.
But generally,
you'll notice-- as I
go through-- that you usually
tend to be leaning more
in the direction of one or the
other, and that's important.
It's important to
know which ones
you are because
then you can invite
other people to the party--
and to be on teams with
you and to work with you--
who are different-- who
actually bring a different kind
of energy and contribution.
And when you're
putting teams together,
you can consciously
think about, how
am I going to have
this team reflect
all of those different kinds
of energies or at least a mix
so it's not just one type?
So here was one of them.
These are people whose
weather they bring with them--
their contribution--
is the fixer.
And the fixer is the
person that's the healer--
they're a restorer,
they're the mender.
These are the people that
you give when a problem needs
to be solved because you know
that that's the thing that they
love.
My friend Joanne used to
talk about her dad, who
was in real estate.
And she'd say her father would
come into work every morning.
He'd sit down at his desk,
he'd roll up his sleeves,
he'd get his cup of coffee
out, and he literally say, OK,
what problems do we have today?
And he was excited--
he was excited to see
what problems showed up.
Now, I don't know about you,
but I do not go into my office
every morning and go, wow what
problems do we have today?
That tends not to be my
relationship with problems.
I have other things
I do, but not that.
So fixers love problems.
That's one of the things
that's in that archetype.
They are really those
kind of people--
useful people to have on
a team-- useful energy
to have because those people
are able to literally take
that attitude towards making
something better and solve it.
Then you have people
that are facilitators,
and this archetype
is people that
are mediators, and
moderators, and go-betweens.
These are the people
that are able to take
all these different groups
and different people
and get them aligned and
going in the same direction.
Amazing skill to have, right?
Amazing contribution to make.
Then you have people
that are storytellers.
And storytellers
are these narrators,
and orators, and minstrels.
These are the people--
whether it's through writing,
or whether it's
through painting,
or whether it's through video,
or whether it's through dance,
or whether it's
through theater--
these are the people that are
able to convey this emotion
and this feeling through story.
And those are incredibly
important people to have
in our world, and in our life,
and on our teams because when
you have that brand of
being a storyteller--
when that's the weather
you bring with you--
you're able to translate
all of these things
in a way that's very powerful.
You know, one of the things
that I learned in my research
was that metaphor and stories
was one of the best way
to get your point
across to somebody--
that when you could speak
in metaphors and stories,
people were able to hear it in
a much different way than when
it was just pure, straight
facts and figures.
Then you have people
that are synthesizers.
And people who-- the
weather they bring with them
as synthesizers, and the energy
that they bring with them--
these are the integrators,
and the blenders,
and the producers.
These are the people
that are able to take
all these disparate things,
put them together, and create
something new.
And those synthesizers
are people
that we rely on because
they're able to see something
new in all of the
different elements.
And it's a really
wonderful, rich archetype
and a really wonderful
and rich brand energy,
because bringing
all those things
together is often the
thing that transforms it--
you know, from a
caterpillar to a butterfly--
transforms into something
brand new and beautiful.
Then you have people
that are mentors,
and the mentors are
interesting because these are
the people whose contribution--
their real essence
of their brand
is being advisors, and
teachers, and guides.
And I love this picture.
This is actually a photo
that I took at the--
I think it's the Wizarding
World of Harry Potter.
I was visiting with some
friends and their kids,
and this little kid saw
one of these Minions.
And the look on
this child's face
was like he had just seen God--
[GASP]
And the parent's there, and the
kid wanders up to the Minion,
and you can see the way
he's just kissing the Minion
and looking at him.
But often, our relationship with
mentors is-- we look up to them
and we admire them so
much because-- it's
the people with this energy--
they're the people that
are really shepherding us along,
and helping us make our goals,
and helping us be the best
people that we can be.
And so this mentor
energy is incredibly
important and valuable
as a contribution.
That's the thing about
all these archetypes.
One isn't better than the other.
One is not more
useful than the other.
One isn't more desirable
than the other.
They're all useful,
and that's why
when you have teams,
or groups, or people
that have a mix of
them together, you
tend to get a better
result because you're
getting all of these
different energies together.
You're getting all of these
different archetypes, which
you can see, you really need
to produce the best outcome.
And really owning the
archetype that we are-- really
owning what our
contribution is, and being
certain about our
contribution, and really
making it is a big
part of people who
have strong personal brands.
They know-- to the
depth of their being--
what that contribution
is, and they trust it.
They trust their
own contribution.
That is what I found
in my research-- was
these people were very solid
in what their contribution was.
It doesn't mean they couldn't
step into other energies,
but they really saw the
depth of that contribution.
Then you have people
that are connectors.
These are some of
my favorite kinds
of energies-- these people
that are connectors.
And these are the networkers,
and the arrangers,
and the coordinators.
These are the people that you'll
go to a party and they'll go,
hey, you should
know such and such,
and I'm going to do an email
and introduce you to this person
because you two should
talk to each other
about this, that,
and the other thing.
They're always putting
people together.
And the people they
put together magically
seem to be perfect for
each other in terms
of the contribution they
can make to each other.
Then you have people
that are visionaries,
and the visionaries are
the conceptualizers,
and the idealists,
and the dreamers.
And these are the
people that are
able to see something
and actually come up
with the concept of
what it should be.
These are the people that are
actually able to stop and go,
hmm, we're doing it
this way, but maybe we
could do it that way.
This is sort of this
ideal that I have.
Then we have people
that are motivators,
and motivators are a little
bit different than mentors.
They might mentor, but
motivators are those people
that can light a fire under us.
They're the cheerleaders,
and the influencers,
and the persuaders.
These are the people
that really can
get a group of people going
on a team, in a group,
individually, with friends.
These are the people that
they just walk in the door,
and what they bring with them
is this instant cheeriness,
and influence, and
ability to persuade.
Then you have the people
that are the makers,
and these are the
artisans, and the creators,
and the inventors.
And these people
could be creating code
or they could be
creating paintings.
I have this thing I talk
about, is the everyday artist.
One of the things I
discovered in my research
was everyone is what I
call an everyday artist.
Every single person
has something
about what they do that's art.
Doesn't matter if
they're computer coding,
it doesn't matter
if they're a doctor,
it doesn't matter if
they're a painter.
Everyone has something that
they do that a part of it
is their art.
It's the way they do it
where they're creating.
And these people
literally are driven
by inventing, and
creating, and art.
That's their whole world.
It's not just painting.
It's not just being on stage.
It could be-- I've known
that are artisans that
that's their makers--
that's their essential self--
their essential contribution,
and what they're making is code
or what they're
making are products.
But it's that feeling of
that they're creating.
Then you have people
that are advocates,
and these are the
people that are
the activists, and the
champions, and the campaigners.
These are the people that
you invite to a dinner party
and they can't help
it-- they're going
to talk about what
they're passionate about
and what they're advocating
for, no matter what-- even
at a dinner party.
That's their energy that
they bring with them.
Then you have people
that are implementers,
and these are achievers, and
administrators, and executors.
These people are awesome because
it's one thing to have ideas,
it's another thing to have those
ideas actually get implemented.
And so these people are really
amazing at taking something
from a concept to an idea
and making it happen.
Then you have people
that are interpreters,
and these are the
people that are
able to translate, and
change, and transform
an idea or a group of
ideas, and interpret it
in a way that's something
completely new happens--
that [? something ?]
completely new
occurs because they're able to
take all those different parts
and not only synthesize them,
but interpret them in a totally
new and different way.
So what gets in the
way of those things?
Those are some of our
contributions and archetypes.
What gets in the way of them?
Well, the first thing is--
is do you know what yours is?
Can you have a sense of
what your archetype is?
Actually, what I'd
love everybody to do
is just kind of quickly
pair up with someone
next to you, and of those
ones that I just ran through,
which one or two do
you think you are?
Which one resonates
most strongly with you?
And then, which one or two
reminded you of someone
you know?
So everybody just get a
partner and really quickly just
with your partner,
share what that is.
Great.
So let me just share some
examples of which one
resonated with you personally.
Which ones resonated
with you personally,
let me just hear some examples.
AUDIENCE: I would
say a visionary.
KAREN LELAND: Visionary?
OK, great.
Who else?
AUDIENCE: I'd say
an implementer.
KAREN LELAND: An implementer?
OK.
See now, what's interesting is
if we put these two together,
they're a perfect pair, right?
Because we have
the vision and then
we have the implementation.
What happens when you have a
team just of all visionaries?
AUDIENCE: Nothing gets done.
KAREN LELAND: They're happy.
They're excited, but nothing
gets done because they're not
implementers.
What happens when you have
a team of all implementers?
AUDIENCE: They can go
in the wrong direction.
KAREN LELAND: They
can-- yeah, they're
awesome at getting
it done, but they
could be going in
the wrong direction,
or they could be going in
a limited direction, which
is why we need
everyone's contribution--
which is why this
diversity of contribution
is really, really important--
why it's important to have
this inclusion of
different people
who have different
contributions to bring in teams,
and groups, et cetera.
Who else?
Let me just hear a
few other examples.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: There's
connectors back here.
KAREN LELAND:
There's connectors?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
KAREN LELAND: You're
all together--
the connectors
are all connected.
OK, perfect.
You managed to find
each other, great.
So how many of you could
see your coworkers in this?
Just raise your hands.
Yeah.
Your bosses?
Your wives?
Anybody see their animals?
Every once in a while
people say to me,
I think my dogs a connector.
I'm like, OK.
So what gets in the way of this?
Well, one of the things I found
in the research was that one
of the big things
that gets in the way--
that creates a
contribution gap--
is our fear of missing out.
And we live in a world
where it's easier than ever
to have this fear of
missing out, isn't it?
Because every time we turn
on the iPhone or the Google--
whatever we're
using-- whatever PDA
we're using-- the Google, the
iPhone, whatever-- every time
we turn it on, what happens?
We look at Facebook
and we see, oh,
that person's living so much
of a better life than I am.
They're having so much
more fun than I am.
And doesn't everyone's life
look so much better than ours?
Come on, tell the truth.
It's like I'm always
looking and going,
well wow, Kim Kardashian
didn't retweet my picture
of my macaroni and cheese.
How come?
I want to be the
mother of dragons.
So what happens is we have
this fear of missing out
that happens-- in part,
we have-- social media's
been wonderful for a lot
of things, and I love it,
but it's also contributed
to this fear of missing out.
It's contributed to this idea
that, somehow, everybody's
living this better
life than we are.
And the fear of missing
out was one of the things
that my research
showed really got
in the way of
people's contribution.
And it also created
a sense of isolation.
It created a sense of, I'm
sort of here in my world
doing my thing, and
other people are
in their world
doing their thing,
and we're not really
always connecting--
even though we might
be connected on social,
we're not always connecting.
So what I found in
the research was
that this fear of missing out
led to a sense of emptiness
that had people not
really believe or have
faith in their contribution--
like their contribution wasn't
enough.
Their contribution was somehow
insufficient or not enough
to bring to the party.
That's one of the things
that gets in the way.
So how do you bridge that gap?
Well, I think you bridge that
gap a couple of the ways,
and one of the
ways you bridge it
is by practicing what
my friend Lynette calls
the joy of missing out.
So instead of the
fear of missing out,
you practice the
joy of missing out.
I love Lynette because I
will say to her, Lynette,
do you want to go to the movie?
And she'll go, yeah, no, I don't
really feel like doing that.
And I'll go, OK well, Lynette
do you want to do this?
No, I don't think so.
It's not like Lynette
doesn't participate.
She just isn't afraid
of missing out on things
so she really has that
joy of not doing things.
And how many times
do we do something
because we have a fear
of missing out on it?
We're just afraid
to say no because we
might miss this opportunity,
or we might miss this person,
or something might happen?
A few years ago--
I love to travel.
Travel is one of my
most favorite things
in the world to do.
And a few years
ago, I got invited
to go with a girlfriend--
a friend of mine
was going to go to Iceland.
And she had a small group
of people put together--
some friends.
So I decided to go to Iceland--
I'd never been there-- to
see the northern lights.
Now, I know that
Iceland is cold,
but I thought Iceland was
cold the way New York is cold.
And what I found
out is, no, Iceland
is not cold the way
New York is cold--
it's much, much colder.
So I, as a result, was not
properly dressed in Iceland,
and it was--
I think it was in
the winter, too.
So I was not properly dressed
in Iceland, and I looked good,
but I was really cold.
And I was so cold that
I actually got violently
sick-- like seriously
sick-- in Iceland.
And so I spent most of my time
in bed with a cold, recovering.
It was just one of those trips
that didn't-- nothing turned
out.
Rarely happens when I travel,
but nothing turned out.
And so I got home from Iceland,
and I was like, OK, that's it.
And Lynette and I have a
good friend named Teresa,
and Teresa said to me-- maybe
a week after I got back from
Iceland--
Karen, a bunch of us are
going to go on a trip.
Do you want to come with us?
And I was like, hell no.
And I think I said
something else,
but I said hell no, I do
not want to go on that trip.
And they were like, oh
no, it'll really be fun.
It's going to be an
interesting thing.
And I was like, no, I don't
want to go on the trip.
It was overseas somewhere.
And then about three months
or four months goes by,
and Teresa's talking
to me about their trip.
And I go-- and I literally say
to her, what do you mean you
guys are going on a trip?
How come you didn't invite me?
And she goes, we did invite you.
You said hell no.
And I said, oh, I must have
been in my post-Iceland.
She goes, yeah, you were
in your post-Iceland phase.
You were not feeling
like going on that trip.
So anyway, they all
went on the trip
and they were sending me
pictures from the bus,
and they're all
having a good time.
And I started feeling that fear
of missing out, like, darn it.
I missed out.
I missed out on
going on that trip.
And then, all of the sudden,
I realized, you know what?
I didn't go on that trip,
but the country they went to
isn't going anywhere.
| didn't go on that
trip, but you know what?
Look at all these
other things I got
to do because I didn't
go on that trip.
And I started to see
how-- even in retrospect--
we look at things,
and we have this fear
of missing out about things
that have already passed.
Does everyone know
what I'm talking about?
And then we spend
our mind, like, oh,
I should have gone
to that meeting,
or I should have
been at that party,
done this thing.
And so this fear of missing
out-- the alternative--
the key to really
giving our contribution
is to step into the
joy of missing out.
It's like really practicing
that if something isn't
the right thing
for us at the time,
we're going to have the
joy of missing out on it.
We're going to have the joy of
saying no to the things that
aren't right and that saying yes
to the things that are right.
So I have a contribution
challenge for you,
and here's the challenge.
It's really in the next month--
only do things that are
really within your greatest
contribution.
Only do things that are really
on the path of your greatest
contribution.
Only say yes to those
things that really feel
like they're within your gift--
the gift that you have to give.
Now obviously, there's
things your boss is going
to ask you to do that you
can't say, oh, I'm sorry,
that's not within my
gift or my contribution.
I won't be doing that.
Yeah, don't do that.
But you know,
there's other things
that you're going to want to say
yes to that really aren't there
out of a fear of missing out.
Just say no to those
things because saying no
to those things has a
certain power to it.
That makes a huge
difference when you
start moving in that direction.
So that's one of things
I found is when people
took on this
contribution challenge,
it made a huge difference.
The other thing is that--
take a look at how you're
represented in terms
of your brand in the world.
So what does that mean?
Number one, in business
that means LinkedIn.
Take a look at your
LinkedIn profile and see--
it doesn't really represent me.
I get calls every
day from people
that ask me to work with
them on their personal brand.
First thing I do is check
out their LinkedIn profiles.
And as many of you know,
your LinkedIn profile is--
a lot of people-- like up
to 77% of the people that
are going to talk to
you or work with you
are going to check you
out on LinkedIn first.
So having your LinkedIn profile
really reflect and represent
you is one of the key things to
having your brand in the world
be solidified.
You know, I always
tell people they
should be Googling themselves
at least once a month.
You just put your
name on Google,
and Google yourself once a
month, and see what comes up.
How are you being
represented in the world?
So your LinkedIn is one of the
places you want to think about,
how are you
representing your brand?
Are you just giving a
recitation of your--
everything you've
done-- of your resume,
or are you actually having
a little bit of-- there
in the summary--
of who you are and
what you contribute.
I don't mean writing
the archetypes in there.
I mean talking a little
bit about what you're
committed to, talking
a little bit about what
it is you bring to the party.
You know, I always tell
people their summaries ought
to have a little bit of
that feeling of, what's
the weather you bring with you?
When that's in your
summary and your Google--
I mean in your
LinkedIn, excuse me--
then it makes a big difference.
People can get a sense of that.
So one is, are you
represented on your LinkedIn
in a way where your
brand really shows up?
Because in the world we live in
today, that's one of the places
people go.
I don't know if you all
have seen this yet, but now,
on my calendar--
on my cell-- when I go
to meet with somebody
I haven't met with before,
a little message will pop up
that says, you're going to
meet with such-and-such soon.
Would you like to see
their LinkedIn profile?
So it's automatically
taking me to see
people's LinkedIn profile
when I'm meeting with someone
I haven't met with before or
it doesn't recognize as someone
I know.
So that's going to
be just standard.
I think in about a year,
that's going to just
be built into every
calendar program
everywhere, regardless
of what you're using.
So that kind of
access to people is
part of how our brands
are getting defined.
So how do you show up online?
What's your LinkedIn look like?
That's the reason LinkedIn's
important-- is because it's
the business-to-business one.
It's the biggest
business-to-business one.
But then, how are you
represented on Facebook?
Listen, I know people who
have stuff on Facebook--
pictures-- shots of taking
tequila shots as they get out
of the ocean half-dressed--
saying really
inflammatory things
politically on both sides of
the aisle-- doesn't matter.
I have people that have
had stuff on their Facebook
that I'm saying, do you want
an employer to really see that?
Do you want a potential
client you're meeting with
to really see that?
Because that's shaping
their narrative about you,
and they can find it.
So part of it is thinking
about how, also, do we
represent ourselves online?
I think we've gotten really
loose about just putting
anything online we want
on Facebook or Twitter,
and while there's a certain
freedom to that-- a freedom
of expression-- there's also
a certain consequence in terms
of how it shapes our
brand in the world.
So it's thinking about the
social media and how are you
represented in social media.
And then the other
thing is thinking
about what I call--
these are brand projects.
What projects do
you take on at work?
What projects do you say yes to
that can help shape your brand,
and what projects do you say no
to because they're really not
on your path?
Oftentimes we don't look
for those brand projects,
and we need to.
We need to look for
projects at work that
help us shape that brand.
And then there's other ways
to start to build your brand,
whether it's a podcast, or
it's blogging, or it's writing,
or it's doing articles, or
it's speaking on panels.
Everyone today-- for
their own career--
has to start to
think about, what
is my strategy for
managing my personal brand?
Obviously, you have to take
a few things into account.
One is, what do the policies
of your company let you do?
There are some
limitations, usually,
with companies about
what we can do.
So given that you're operating
within those policies,
what are you going to do?
The other thing is,
what are your gifts?
If you're a great writer,
then you should probably
be doing some writing.
You should probably be
blogging somewhere or at least
contributing to some articles
if you're a great writer.
If you're a great speaker, maybe
you should be doing a podcast
or being interviewed on a
podcast for your expertise
or your area.
If you're really a
good speaker, maybe you
should be on a panel for a
conference for your area.
Those are the kinds
of things that you
want to start to think about
building because they take
your contribution
from being something
abstract to something tangible.
And it's one thing for us to
know what our contribution is
and feel it--
it's another thing to make
it tangible in our companies
and in the world.
And so it's really
on us to make sure
we're shaping our
brands out in the world
in a way where
people can get it.
And by the way, when I
say shaping our brands,
I don't mean lying,
exaggerating,
making things up--
I'm not a fan of any of that.
I'm talking about the authentic
expression of who we are
and what's effective for us.
But too many people I see
really don't take enough effort
to shape their brand.
One, they think they maybe don't
need to because of the level
they're at.
Two, they don't think they
need to because they're already
gainfully employed, and they're
not looking for another job.
But the reality
is, is those things
do start to shape our brand.
I'll give you one
really simple example.
This was years ago.
A friend of mine
told me this story.
She used to work in a
company with a woman,
and the woman was like a
mid-level manager in a Fortune
500 company.
Her name was Susan.
And Susan would get
in the elevator,
and oftentimes-- just
because of the floor
she was on and the
timing of her meetings--
she would often find
herself in the elevator
with the CEO of the company.
He'd say, Susan,
how are you today?
I'm fine.
How are you?
It's good.
How's everything going?
It was a little rainy today.
Oh, was snowing today.
And that was the degree
of their conversation.
And then Susan started
working on her personal brand.
And she said one
day she realized
that how she must seem to the
CEO is like the weather girl
because every time he
asked her how she was,
that's what she talked about.
So she started to
get in the elevator,
and he would say, Susan,
how are you today?
And she goes, I'm great.
And he'd go, really?
That's good.
And she'd go, yeah, my
team and I are working
on a really fabulous project.
And every time she saw
the CEO, she would just
do a little bit like that.
And within a few
months, she said
she had been invited
to be on a task team
that he was running for a major
initiative in the organization
because she reshaped
his experience of her.
He reshaped his
experience of her brand.
So while we're not trying
to do anything, again,
that's exaggerating or lying--
we're trying to be authentic.
It's important to be
authentic in our brands.
We have to do it in a way
where other people can get it.
If they can't get it
and get the message,
there's no real point to it.
So just remember
that it's not enough
for you to know what the
weather is you bring with you--
you have to translate
it into ways
that the people you work
with, that the people
in the outside world
can actually see,
can actually feel,
that starts to create
that narrative about yourself.
So here's the thing I
want to leave you with.
It's not what you
know that's important,
it's knowing what's important.
That's what makes a difference,
is knowing what's important.
It's not the script
that you follow,
it's really the script that
you write for yourself.
And lastly, it isn't
really the weather
you find but the weather
you bring with you
that makes the
biggest difference.
So thank you very much for
your time and your attention.
Thank you.
It's been a pleasure to be here.
[APPLAUSE]
And I am going to
take some questions.
So please, anybody
have any questions
about anything-- about any
aspect of personal branding?
I think we have mics
right there, right?
Is that where the mics are?
OK, fantastic.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: So you talk
about projecting internally
what you bring, but
I was just wondering
if you have any advice around
just understanding what you're
projecting to other people?
So I think we can know ourselves
very well but knowing, also,
what other people
see and getting
feedback on that to make
sure that we're [INAUDIBLE]
KAREN LELAND: Yeah,
that's a great question
because here's what happens.
It's like you said-- we think
we know how we're coming across,
but I always say you can't see
the inside of your own eyelids.
It's really hard to tell.
So I think one of the things--
there's a couple
of ways to do that.
One is to have people
that you trust--
and you trust not only
the way they look at you
and their ability to see you--
but you trust that they'll
be honest with you--
and you can ask them,
how do you think
I came across in that meeting?
What do you think my brand is?
One of things I always
tell all new clients
to do is I tell them to go
talk to six people they know
and say, if you
were to just give me
a few descriptions of what you
think my personal brand are,
what are they?
And people often
come back and go--
they're shocked at
how consistent it is.
That's what people
are shocked at-- is
how do six different people from
six different places know that?
The shortcut to
this, by the way,
is ask your spouse,
or your boyfriend,
or girlfriend because
they always know.
They always know.
So that's one thing--
is really what--
is you can ask the
people that you know.
You can also be more
formal and actually--
when you get your 360s or when
you do something like that--
you can ask people to give
you their impression of what
your personal brand is as
an additional piece of that.
But it is important
to get that feedback.
The thing is, you have to
establish a relationship
with people where they're going
to be honest about giving you
that feedback, and that
means no consequences.
So you have to say to
people, you can say anything
that you really see, and
there will be no consequences.
I won't hold it against you.
I won't bring it up, et cetera.
That's one really good
way to do it, thank you.
What else?
Other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I got one.
What about people--
I've seen a lot lately,
people that rebrand their name--
their own name themselves.
So I see a lot of
executives that-- all
of a sudden-- their
signature's signed off
with a shorter, different name.
I've got friends
that are lawyers
that now call themselves
slightly different versions
of their name
because they think--
for example, one--
her name's Kate.
She now calls herself
Katie, and everyone else
to call herself Katie.
What's your take on--
I think our executive teams seem
to do this branding training,
and then they've all
got different names?
What's your take on--
like I've always thought
you can't choose--
it has to be organic,
so it seems--
KAREN LELAND: It's like, your
parents gave you that name,
you should stick with it.
AUDIENCE: It doesn't
feel authentic.
So do you teach that, or
what's your take on that?
KAREN LELAND: Now,
I'm-- what's your name?
AUDIENCE: My name's
Brent, and-- yeah--
KAREN LELAND: Brent.
Because we can make your
the Big-B. I don't know.
No, I don't generally teach
that people change their name
unless they have a really--
a name that's problematic.
So I had a woman who called
me, and her company was named--
no kidding-- Isis, and it
was a health care company.
And she called me because she
was very upset, because she
says, I've had this name
of my company for 20 years,
and I don't want to change it.
And I'm like, look I'm
sorry, but there's just
no way around this one.
You are going to have to change
the name of your company.
So are there times when you
have to change your name?
Yes, but I'm not-- in general--
a fan.
I'm not criticizing anyone.
If that's what they
want to do, that's fine.
I don't think that's really
what rebranding is about.
To me that's kind of a
shallow way to rebrand.
I think what real rebranding
is about is when you've
discovered-- it's like I used to
have a friend that used to say,
before you can have
a new reputation,
you have to be responsible
for the reputation you
have currently.
So, to me, what
real rebranding is,
is when you realize you
have a certain reputation,
and it's not what
you want, and it's
time to really make some
deep changes in yourself
and externally to that.
So I think sometimes people do--
and I don't know
any of these people,
so I'm not saying
they've done that.
But I think
sometimes what people
do is they try to fix
their brand with a name
change, or a logo change,
or just changing--
I used to wear blue jackets,
now I'm wearing red jackets.
And all of that's fine,
but that isn't really
what makes an impact.
That isn't really
the depth of branding
that really makes a difference.
So I think the problem is when
we try to rebrand in a shallow
way-- or we try to rebrand
just on the surface,
I guess would be a
better way to say it--
when we try to brand
on the surface,
it lacks a certain
impact and depth,
and you run the risk
of seeming inauthentic.
And that's the problem with
that kind of surface rebranding.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, it's a great question.
Please.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm curious if--
in your research-- you
found helpful insights
about vulnerability
because you're
calling us to be authentic-- to
kind of put ourselves out there
and be more open to scrutiny.
So I'm kind of wondering if
that surfaced in your research,
and how does that play out?
KAREN LELAND:
That's-- first of all,
that's such a great question,
and that absolutely surfaced
in my research.
So how many people here have
seen Brene Brown's TEDx talk--
of the Houston TEDx talk on
the power of vulnerability?
Anybody seen that in here?
If you haven't, I want
to highly recommend that.
That's a really powerful
video, but, similar to
what Brene Brown is talking
about in that video,
I found that the people that had
the strongest personal brands--
positive personal
brands-- let me
qualify it like that
because there can
be negative personal brands.
But people that
had the strongest,
positive personal
brands were people
that were seen as
being authentic,
and what made them
authentic was their humility
and their vulnerability.
So they were willing to
say, I made that mistake.
I screwed that up.
I'm trying to do this,
and I failed at it.
They didn't look like they
were all together-- like,
oh, I've had it all
together, and everything's
perfect in my life,
and I have 2.7 kids,
and my marriage is fabulous,
and don't I look great?
They didn't have that.
They were really willing
to say, I'm struggling.
I'm struggling with my kids.
I'm struggling with my marriage.
I'm struggling in my job.
I'm having a trouble with
this particular part.
I don't mean they were
dumping it on people,
but they were really,
really willing
to be authentic, and
honest, and vulnerable
about their struggles.
How many of you-- when
you work with somebody
or you know somebody who's
willing to be authentic
with you about their
struggles-- you actually
feel more connected to that
person when they share that?
How many people have
had that experience?
Just raise your hands.
And it's so funny
because I think
we're afraid that's going
to drive people away.
But in my research,
what I found is
that people who are willing to
embrace that vulnerability--
that's what made them
authentic, and that's
what made other people
able to connect with them
and with their brands.
And they were actually more
able to make their contribution
out of that vulnerability
than less able to make it.
So yeah, that's
a great question.
Thank you.
What else?
Other questions, please.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name is Brooke.
KAREN LELAND: Hi, Brooke.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for being here.
KAREN LELAND: Pleasure.
AUDIENCE: Kind of a
tag-along question to that--
at what point is an overshare--
is it an overshare?
And at what point are
certain taboo subjects--
for example, like relationship
issues, addiction,
something like that-- what if
you want to share that openly
and vulnerably, but--
KAREN LELAND: That is
such a great question.
Well, one thing is--
I'll tell you a little
story, which is--
when I was writing my last book,
"The Brand Mapping Strategy"
book, somebody called
me and they told
me to go online and
look at this thing up,
and this woman had
been on Facebook,
and she had been sharing
about some guy she
had dated the night before,
and it was very explicit,
and whatever.
I won't tell you any
details because that
would be oversharing.
It was very explicit.
And then somebody else said to
her, why are you putting this
publicly on Facebook?
And she goes, oh no, I
thought I was sharing it
in the private area.
And they go, no, you're
sharing it publicly.
Everyone can see this.
And it became this whole
thing, and she actually
got fired from her job
because her client saw it,
and it was pretty risque stuff.
So, I think, one thing is I see
a lot of sharing on Facebook--
that when I see it,
I cringe, and I go,
that's too much
information-- that's
oversharing because
anybody can see it.
A client can see it.
An employer can see it.
So we used to have this thing
we used to say, which is,
don't put anything in public--
on the Facebook, Twitter,
whatever-- don't put anything
out there in public
you wouldn't want
printed on the front page
of The New York Times.
So when it comes to social
media, that's one of the ways
to think about it--
how would I feel
if this was on the front
page of The New York Times?
Would I be OK with that?
If you would be, then put it.
If you wouldn't, then don't.
I think when it comes
to the personal sharing,
I think you have to
make a distinction--
and the distinction is the
container of the relationship
you have with the person.
In other words, is
this person a coworker
but they're also a friend?
And you talk about
personal things--
I think when there's
that container,
then it's fine, especially
if you have a confidentiality
agreement to share those
things with each other.
I think when the container
is that you're coworkers
but you're not really
personal friends,
you have to think about, is
that information something
that's going to
burden the person
because they're going to feel
like they have to keep it
from other people, so you're
now putting a burden on them?
Or is it something
that's going to affect
their relationship with
you in a way that's
negative or difficult?
So I think part of it is-- it's
really a case-by-case basis,
but we have a big problem in
today's world with oversharing.
I mean, how many of you
go on Facebook sometimes
and you literally go,
why did that person
put that on Facebook?
You wonder that.
How many people of you
have wondered that?
I mean, I could give you
so many more examples,
and it's-- now we've got
people showing videos of things
and I'm like, why are they
putting that video on Facebook?
Does that help?
Yeah, that's very good.
Thank you.
Other questions, please.
AUDIENCE: So I've
been thinking a lot
about juggling kind of an
aspirational personal brand
and something that you really
actually haven't done yet.
I feel like a couple of
my peers would say, well,
I'm a marathon runner.
And you'd say, oh well,
what marathons have you run?
Well you know, I'm
training for one.
Or I'm a community architect.
Well, what communities
have you built?
And so it's not
dishonest because there's
a genuine desire to get to
that, but it just ends up
feeling a little shallow
and without integrity,
even though they
do have the skills
or they're working towards
getting to that brand,
if that makes sense.
So how would you recommend
working towards something
and trying to get yourself
into that next step
while not being dishonest?
And it kind of seems
like it's lying, almost.
KAREN LELAND: Right.
Yes, that's a great question
because we have a lot of--
things get hyped up today.
We hype things up.
Like people say, I'm a writer.
Really?
Well, what have you written?
Well, nothing but I'm writing.
So it's like-- I
think part of it
is we've lost that distinction
of what those achievements are.
So I think part of it is--
you really just said it--
it's being honest with people.
I don't think you need to say,
I'm a-- remember the thing
about roles?
Marathon runner's a role.
You don't have to identify
yourself by that role to say,
one of my projects this year is
I'm training to run a marathon.
I'm really into the
athletics this year.
I'm really trying to
have a breakthrough
in my athletic ability.
I'm training to run a marathon.
You don't have to give yourself
the label, and I think we are--
again, I think part of it is
we get into this thing this day
where we feel like we
have to label everything.
I'm a writer.
I'm a marathon runner.
I'm an artist-- whatever it is.
And part of it
is-- if we can let
go of the identification
with the role,
then we can talk about
it from the point
of view of what we're learning.
You know, I'm studying Spanish.
You know, I'm learning
to run a marathon.
You know, I'm-- what was
the other example you gave?
AUDIENCE: The
community architect.
KAREN LELAND: Yeah,
I'm studying how
to be a community
architect, or I'm
really passionate about
community architecture.
We don't have to have
ourselves in a fixed
position as the role.
Does that make sense?
And part of what happens
with social media
is we get encouraged to
categorize ourselves a lot.
We get encouraged to
categorize ourselves--
I can check the boxes for
all of the different things--
like that's what our brand is.
And what I'm saying is our
brand isn't really those roles.
It's what we bring to it--
it's what we contribute.
Like for myself--
I consider myself
a lifelong learner.
I'm always going to
be learning something.
When I was in my 40s,
I took up tap dancing.
I wasn't very good at it,
but I would never say,
I'm a tap dancer.
No one would ever say that.
But I would say to people,
yeah, I'm studying tap dancing.
It's really fun.
I'm learning a lot--
because I didn't have to
be identified in the role.
So it's like it's a matter
of what-- like right now,
I'm learning to make jewelry,
but I would never call myself
a jeweler.
I could, but I
wouldn't because I
don't need to be
identified with that role.
Right now, it's just like, oh,
I'm learning something new.
I'm learning to make
jewelry, how fun.
So I think part of it is
we want to get everything
kind of like boxed down to,
these are our seven roles
and these are-- the seven roles
are what define who we are.
And what I'm saying
is the opposite
is, the roles aren't
really what we are.
It's the quality.
So maybe the quality for the
person running the marathon
is challenging themselves,
so the thing to talk about
is, I love to challenge
myself, and my new way
of challenging myself is I'm
learning to run marathons.
Does that make sense?
Because then you're focusing
on the quality rather than
the role itself.
And that's a really
key point because we
do tend to lead with our roles.
We tend to lead with our
resumes like that's our brand,
and it's not-- or that that's
our contribution, and it's not.
Well, I really want to thank
you for your time and attention.
I know how hard it is
to get away from work
and come to something like this,
so thank you for your time.
I hope this was useful for you,
and if you have any questions,
please feel free
to reach out to me.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]